she's alright Monster Hunter generations
ultimate which gets their version I'm
gonna check this thing out here man
listen really cool looking good
finally the switch gets their shot
[Music]
building up right now
[Music]
now do you play the main console version
of this also
oh okay gotcha
you know
[Music]
beyond the switches Owen Stewart you
should get it off oh yeah absolutely you
got that portability man
so does it does it compare to like a
full French version of the console nice
[Music]
gotcha little bit different okay
[Music]
exactly
yep so as is a hardcore monster on a
player you approved all so far of the of
the version nice okay
[Applause]
[Music]
Hey well it looks good man it looks
really good
[Music]
that's it
[Music]
yes yeah nice looking good looking good
[Music]
now wonder if they'll have any type of
cooperative or anything like that mold
like local right yeah you play okay I
got you Monster Hunter generations
ultimate everybody is intense and
insolent the getting their Monster
Hunter on checking it out over the
shoulder Wow looks good you liking it up
you're a fan are you a big monster fans
and I get because of this you get a
switch I got you that's get a little
watch the quite a little bit
she is getting a switch now y'all
[Music]
it looks really good I've been man I
have to admit so you are miss Martha you
play these games
Wow Wow
that's awesome that is awesome wonder if
we got a release date for this for the
switch version yet I believe it's out in
Japan right
gotcha cool cool
and now wait I might have to I might
have to join you on this one it's
looking good
it doesn't get out I might have to take
this on the go yes and just constantly
keep building a character yeah
absolutely
now do you think it has the depth of the
console version
awesome
[Music]
animation for graces
which in the process of doing right now
break it down what you doing down here
[Music]
it's monster one hunts our generation's
ultimate thank you so much willing us
our film yeah yeah it looks like another
one on the switch this is gonna sell
well this is gonna do well y'all